SPEAKER 1: The
Founders understood
that slavery was wrong
on principle, that it's,
by definition, an injustice.
And they understood it as such.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hamilton and Madison both
referred to slaves as men.
This is a critical insight,
because if slaves are men,
if slaves are human
beings, then that
means that they have
inalienable natural rights.
And that means that
slavery can only
rest on the basis
of positive law,
that it's, by
definition, an injustice.
And they understood it as such.
Thomas Jefferson, in one of
the most famous statements
on slavery to come out
of the American Founding,
query 18 in "Notes on
the State of Virginia,"
explains that slavery is
at war with human nature
and with justice.
He says it's bad for
slaves because it teaches
them to hate their country,
and it teaches them
to lack self-assertion.
But it's also bad for masters.
It teaches masters
to become tyrants.
It warps them.
It teaches them to have
contempt for the rights
of other human beings.
And once they learn
to have contempt
for the rights of
their slaves, they then
transfer that and
learn to have contempt
for the rights of others
who are not slaves.
Finally, it's bad for society.
It's bad for the
country as a whole.
Jefferson says that we are
so wrong on the question
of slavery that it is certain
that God will punish us
if we don't get it right.
In fact, he says if
it ever came down
to a contest between
slaves and masters
over the future of the
country, Jefferson says,
quote, "The Almighty
has no attribute which
can take side with us in
such a contest," unquote.
So, in short, we can see pretty
quickly that the Founding
Fathers understood that
they had a colossal problem
on their hands, that slavery
was a massive injustice.
And they understood it as such.
What did the Founders
do about slavery?
Because again, to say that
they did not end slavery
altogether is not
the same as saying
that they did nothing about it.
For instance,
during the founding
and early American period,
nine states became free states.
All of the states, the original
states north of Maryland--
so from Pennsylvania
northward-- became free states,
abolished slavery in
one way or another.
Slave states eased
their manumission laws.
Now, a manumission is simply an
individual act of emancipation
where an individual owner
frees an individual slave.
So it was made easier
to free one's slaves
in the Southern states
that retain slavery.
And as a result, thousands
of slaves were manumitted.
Now, this does not end
the institution of slavery
altogether.
But it is certainly
important to you
if you are one of those
thousands who was manumitted
during this period.
We also see instances of
Southern courts favoring
the claims of slaves who
are suing for their freedom.
In fact, this is how the
Dred Scott case got its start
in the Missouri State courts.
In ruling against
Dred Scott in 1850,
the Missouri Supreme
Court admitted
that if Dred Scott's case
had come before the court,
say, 10 years earlier, they most
certainly would have freed him.
But times had changed,
and so they were no longer
honoring the friendly agreement
that they had with free states
to respect the laws of
those states because
of the intensification of
the slavery controversy.
There were also reforms
in the slave states
that tended to recognize
the humanity of slaves.
By the beginning of
the 19th century,
North Carolina had reformed its
laws so that killing a slave
carried the same penalty
as killing a free person.
It was still hard to
obtain a conviction,
but at least this
is a recognition
that a slave is, in fact,
a human being and not
an article of livestock.
There was the abolition of the
slave trade, which was legally
abolished in 1807, and the
abolition took effect in 1888.
Later on, the slave
trade was declared
to be piracy, making it
a death penalty offense.
This was a law
which was extremely
hard to enforce in
the age of sale,
but at least you have a
declaration of a commitment
to end this inhumane practice.
If one looks to the
Constitution itself,
one notices that
conspicuously absent
from the entire Constitution,
including the provisions that
deal directly with slavery,
is the word "slave"
in any variation.
Madison, Frederick Douglass,
Abraham Lincoln all
came to the same conclusion
about why this was the case.
They did not want to taint the
document with any implication
that slavery existed, so
that if someone came along
in the future without
any particular knowledge
of our history or
politics, they could not
read the original Constitution
and know that slavery
had been a part of it.
If one turns to the particular
provisions in the Constitution
that deal with
slavery, we also can
see ambiguities and
compromises that
reflect the Founders' desire to
seize slavery gradually removed
from our society.
The Importation Clause
in Article I Section 9
was looked upon by many
people as a death sentence
for slavery.
It was widely
believed at the time
that slave populations could
not be self-sustaining,
that only continual importation
would allow slavery to survive
in a particular community.
And so many people,
such as James Wilson,
believed that cutting
off the slave trade
killed slavery itself.
And that proved to be
largely true in many places,
except in America.
In America, the
slave population,
contrary to expectations,
proved to be self-supporting.
Finally, if one is looking
at what the Founders did
about slavery, perhaps
the most important thing
that they did about slavery was
to pass a piece of legislation
called the Northwest Ordinance.
So the Northwest territory
was the full area
in which the federal government
could control slavery,
and the Northwest Ordinance
banned it in perpetuity.
And it was passed by a
large margin in Congress
both times under both
forms of government.
This was significant
in a number of ways.
Indiana, when it petitioned for
statehood, asked for the right
to be exempt from the
Northwest Ordinance.
Now, one does not ask
for that exemption
if one wants to be a free state.
And the federal
government told them
that they were not exempted.
They could remain free under
the Northwest Ordinance,
or they could
become a free state.
So it certainly
made one state that
might have been a slave
state into a free state.
It provided, when we got to the
Civil War, an enormous amount
of manpower and
material resources
for the Union war effort.
And finally, the language
of the slavery prohibition
in the Northwest
Ordinance became the basis
for the 13th Amendment to the
Constitution outlawing slavery
nationwide by
constitutional amendment.
So many things were done
to restrict slavery--
to hem it in, as
Lincoln would later
say-- within the narrowest
limits of necessity.
SPEAKER 2: Thank
you for watching.
We hope you're enjoying
our Highlights series
and invite you to explore
all of Hillsdale College's
online courses.
They are free and for
everyone who loves to learn.